well good morning everybody uh thank you
very much for being here to discuss
these two
unresolved fatal pedestrian hit and runs
that are being investigated by this
bureau
today and over the last couple days and
weeks
we're grateful to our media partners for
helping us highlight this and
hopefully helping come to a resolution
the las vegas metropolitan police
department traffic bureau operates
throughout our entire community
before they get into the specifics of
these two cases i want to take a moment
to thank them so much
thanks sergeant mcauliffe thank
lieutenant munson behind me
for the work they do every day to keep
us safe they focus primarily on
education enforcement as a last result
but making sure that our community is
aware of
aware of their surroundings from the
beginning of the process
the way we engineer our roads all the
way through to the enforcement piece
of course with education in the middle
that's really the focus of this bureau
and they do a tremendous job with the
resources they have
throughout our entire valley we're
grateful to them
and we're also here as i mentioned to
highlight these two cases the 15th and
21st
pedestrian fatality in metro's
jurisdiction when you think about that
we're now at 23 23 pedestrian fatalities
in our jurisdiction and it's only march
way surpassing last year
there are lots of reasons for it but we
want to take this opportunity to remind
everyone to be aware
be cognizant of their surroundings but
slow down when you're in your vehicles
in our community take an extra minute
be cognizant that we are returning to
more populated roadways as we continue
to reopen our community
and this is really going to be a joint
effort by everybody
and we also are here to highlight these
hit and runs because the community plays
a imperative role in helping resolve
these cases
the team here does an incredible job
often times with
hardly any information to go on they
work so hard to resolve these cases
but in in those like these two that
we're here to talk about today
you have such little information to go
on that it really is up to our community
to get involved pay attention
take notice of uh people in their lives
that might be acting a little bit
unusual
and invite everybody to call
702-828-3786 this team here investigates
every lead that they get
and of course crime stoppers is also an
important partner in this
anyone who wants to give information
anonymously can do that through
crime stoppers at
[Music]
again thank you 702-385-5555 for coming
out today um we've called you here of
course this morning to talk about the
death of two people
and i want that to sink in for a minute
that's two people that aren't coming
home that could have been any of you
or me that didn't come home and the
drivers of these two incidences
fled the scene they left not calling for
medical attention
not rendering any aid to those people
they left them to lie there to die on
the roadways
that is not acceptable that is not the
community that we are part of
these drivers we're asking for the
public's help in
identifying them and i'm going to give
you some specific information reference
these two fatalities
to hopefully jog the memories of some
people that might have been out there
who saw what occurred i want to address
the drivers and how important it is to
stay on scene
this year as commissioner talked about
we are at
six hit and run fatalities that we're
not even three months we're just
ending three months into the year six
last year we had ten total hit and run
fatalities for the year
we're at six that's six people that fled
the scene
and in most cases what we're finding is
it's false
concerns that they have why they flee
the scene when they're interviewed after
they're taken into custody
they say oh i thought i had warrants
they say um you know i didn't have a
driver's license or i was i had a
suspended driver's license or no
insurance
but the fact of the matter is they left
the scene letting somebody lay on the
road and die
that is not acceptable to us
so i'm going to talk about the first
fatality that happened on february 20th
20 2021 at 9 24 p.m
at twain avenue and paul verdes street
in this case the pedestrian crossed the
road near a crosswalk
against a pedestrian control device and
was struck by a vehicle and killed
the suspect vehicle that we're looking
for is burgundy or maroon in color
mid-size suv with possible driver side
damage
the driver left this pedestrian lying
there in the roadway as i said before
to die and i keep saying that because i
want that to resonate with everybody
these are people and they're dying on
our roadways laying there bleeding to
death
dying and nobody did anything to stop
them
many times people drive by a wreck and
they don't they don't realize they call
the police they thought somebody already
did call
we're asking you to call anyways give us
whatever information you have so that we
can
do a further investigation
in this case if the driver had stayed at
the scene
the investigation would have not found
that driver at fault in this case the
pedestrian was at fault
but that pedestrian is no longer with us
today because that driver didn't stay
and call for medical attention which is
desperately needed in these type of
collisions
the second fatality hit and run occurred
on march 14th
2021 at 8 48 pm
lake me boulevard north of lincoln road
in this case the pedestrian darted
across oncoming traffic
not in a crosswalk and was struck by a
vehicle
and at the end the end result of that
was the death of that pedestrian as well
and this driver again didn't stop didn't
render aid
didn't do what they should have done in
this case
there are vehicle parts left behind that
belonged to a 2007 to 2009 toyota camry
and also some gray paint flex was left
on the roadway as well from that vehicle
so we're looking for a possible toyota
camry 2007-2009
grand color both of these drivers
left the scene and both of these drivers
if
they would have stayed on scene were not
at fault in this collision
but now they're looking at serious
felony charges and what people may not
know if you leave the scene of an
accident
where somebody is injured or dies you
could suffer a felony charge of up to 20
years in prison
20 years in prison let that resonate
with those who are driving
who think they can run you're looking at
20
years in prison if you would have stayed
you could have saved a life and that's
the most important message here is if
they would have stayed behind
and called for medical response they
could have saved the lives of these
people possibly
i know i seem like i'm coming off really
strong but it is important because we
are on a path that we do not want to
continue we want to stop this
and it's up to our community it's up to
all of us to make sure that that happens
again we need your help and i'm asking
that if anyone has any information to
come forward these families need closure
these families need justice and the
people that responsible
need to face the consequences of their
actions
as commissioner said before they can
remain anonymous by calling crime
stoppers
or you can go online even now through
your phone app
and call crimestoppers of nv.com
you can do that through online or you
can message our facebook at lvnpdtraffic
and on our facebook we are going to be
highlighting all of our hit and run
fatalities that we've had that are not
solved
again i want to thank the commissioner
for his support
as well as i want to give a special
thank you to all of you here in the
media that are in this room today
because if it isn't for you we wouldn't
get our message out and you help us
uh accomplish our mission to provide
exceptional police services
in partnership with our community and i
thank you again for um everything you
guys do for us
if you have questions
can you explain what we're looking at i
mean what i'm going to bring
the actual case agent on this because he
can speak specifically to that
uh incident it's going to be detective
salisbury
what was your question about the video
it's uh not necessarily the cars in the
parking lot you're looking at but the
backdrop and in the backdrop you'll see
that 2007
to 2009 toyota camry traveling westbound
on lake mead
in this instance that's about all the
evidence we have to go off of
we have a blurry video of a car that we
wouldn't have identified
had those parts not been left behind and
that's why we need the public's help
in identifying this vehicle and the
driver we
it's not like tv where we can zoom in
and enhance
and solve everything based on a grainy
blurry video that we have we need the
public's help
in identifying that friend that
co-worker that family member who has
a 2007 to 2009 toyota camry that's
gray and is now not being driven or
is in a wreck that they can't explain
we need the public's help with that
yes what goes into these investigations
you mentioned
pain on the roadway how thorough are
they um
it's a very broad question how how
thorough
are the investigations we investigate
everything
as thorough as we can we exhaust all
leads until we have no other resources
left
and most of the time that results in a
conviction we get
many of our drivers in custody on these
two instances we don't that's why we're
asking for the public's help
we spoke about half a dozen fatal but
four people have been
arrested on the other four yes
are there factors that are contributing
do you think
to this uh spike that we've seen over
the last few weeks
this is not just a high number
for this year but that's a high number
for that stretch
i mean that's a absolutely and while we
can talk about many different factors
on the frequency of these fatals
ultimately i'm going to tell you the the
biggest factor
that i've seen in my last 15 years of
investigating traffic crashes
is speed and impairment whether it's the
pedestrian that's
impaired whether it's the driver that's
impaired impairment's commonly commonly
a factor
and the other one is speed if in these
instances even when the pedestrians that
fall
if that driver had been going a little
bit slower
many many of these can be avoided
are the investigations taxing on the
team um
um taxing yes of course we do a lot of
hard work we
respond to anywhere in the neighborhood
of 120 to 150 of these
each year and there's only eight of us
that's we're we're out in the roadways
in the middle of the night
often how confident are you that
these people be identified and arrested
i i'm counting on the public's help
in order for a conviction to be made in
this case
i need those people to come forward
somebody knows something
a person doesn't just hit and kill
somebody on a road and remain completely
silent
somebody's friend their family their
co-worker knows that they did this
that's the person i'm looking for to do
the honest right thing and come forward
because the driver
that isn't coming forward that person's
a coward we already know that they're
they're not taking responsibility for
their actions
i'm counting on that person that knows
the driver to do the right thing
and report them so we can at least have
a lead to go off of
and in those cases when that happens yes
we're going to make a conviction there
there's going to be somebody who's going
to be held accountable
at what point do you have to call a
family and say
i try not to give up and lose hope on
any case because
we we've had them i i we had one hit
run that we solved and it was like 15
months after the fact
finally the evidence comes in and we get
forensics back and we're able to make
that arrest
that's great it so i try not to ever
give up
give up hope to that family but in this
case specifically on our march 14th
crash
i've already spoken to the family and no
let them know what the amount of
evidence we have which is very limited
is your message out there for
pedestrians also who's the right thing
maybe it
absolutely is pedestrians that are out
there you have to keep yourself safe
we in our industry we call it don't be
dead right
if you're going to walk out in a
crosswalk you still need to be cognizant
of your surroundings don't cross
thinking i have the right of way and not
looking for traffic because when that
vehicle hits you you're you're soft and
squishy compared to that vehicle you're
gonna get hurt or killed
be cognizant of your surroundings when
i'm walking
down the street on the sidewalk with my
daughters
i i'm like a i'm hyper vigilant on
everything around me because i've seen
this too often i want to make sure that
my daughters and i are safe while we're
walking on the sidewalk because too
often you see these crashes where
vehicles are
coming up onto the sidewalk like we had
two weeks ago
so these drivers wouldn't face any
charges relating to the crash itself
they weren't called there but they will
face charges right correct
on march 14th i don't know if that
driver's impaired or had something
going on but i have somebody that's
traveling down the roadway at night
at a lawful speed if that driver's not
impaired and they hit and killed that
pedestrian remain there
there's absolutely no charges that would
be filed in that case
is the charges for hitting somebody
being impaired uh
is it similar to the charge of uh
fleeing the scene
uh somebody as far as the consequences
yes we're one of the only states that do
that where are
leaving the scene are hit and run
charges the consequences are
up to and including the same consequence
for
driving under the influence resulting in
substantial bali harm or death
thank you for your time doesn't have any
other questions
no just again thank you all for coming
and helping us get out the word
crime stoppers is three five five five
five five thank you
thank you thank you everybody